work on it and change it it can manifest
in different ways it may not be in
cheating but it may not it may be in
different areas and work in other
relationships they may be just dodgy in
however they approach different things
it shall send it to you in the DMs I got
you
um I just found it uh no because the the
thing is like so I asked my dad I was
like Dad do people change
and he said to me this is my dad's
wisest person I know okay swear to God
he knows everything about everything and
he goes yes
they get worse over time
so anything that you see like at a young
person like I swear it is going to get
worse it does not get better
and because you can't change like okay I
used to drink I don't I don't drink
anymore but there's always going to be a
part of me that wants to drink and
that's never gonna go away and so any
guy that dates me like he he knows there
might be a chance that I'm gonna want to
drink again because that is what I used
to do it's just like I'm just watching
this uh Netflix series
um it's called the I'm a killer and so
this guy killed somebody he may say like
oh I
um changed my life gave my life to
Christ but that that instinct it may be
suppressed it may be in the back of his
mind but it's still there you can't
forget who who you were and what you've
done is still going to be there and it
is going to affect you in some type of
way not saying that you're going to do
it again but they're still there but
you'll probably do it well I was saying
that what I was saying earlier guys I
100 agree with what you're saying if
you're promiscuous in your past you're
more likely to be promiscuous in the
future my problem is like
with promiscuity as you said women are
Great Pretenders and they fool Mr beta
mail
how does these men who often say ah cool
I want a woman who's got less bodies
than 10. how did they even find this is
my point
you're saying like oh yes I'm saying
most women are bigger hoes than you'd
think yeah because why why
why shouldn't a woman not be sexual I
don't understand like the reason is
if you if you have the desire to get
married and to be with that one person
you're essentially making it harder on
yourself to physically be like okay I'm
going to be with this person forget
about all these other dudes because
there's things like awful annoying where
you have this dude that just rocked your
world just changed your life and you can
never get him out of your brain because
of all the partners you've been with and
then you have just areas where if you
slept with all these dudes your ability
to is a parabond parabon with your
husband is going to be hard because
you've just freely given yourself to all
these other dudes to where when it comes
to your husband is going to be like yeah
I love him but he doesn't do this this
like this person did that person that
person did so it's like you have all
these bits and pieces of these other
dudes that just do men not have the same
thing
not in the same way women do because
it's like weird men can love multiple
women at the same time so it's kind of
like if a guy has an ex-girlfriend is
weird I talk to I talk to this pickup
artist like um I went to a pickup artist
boot camp this dude so good with women
like literally slept with like three
girls in three days like whatever and he
told me he's like yeah the girl's after
me they always get seem to get married
after like I sleep with them and he's
like I still get mad I'm like do you
want them I'm like he's like no
I'm good I just and it's because men
release a hormone that makes them like
territorial so men can love multiple
women on the same time because that's
natural to them there was 17 women
reproducing for every one guy where
women can only love one man because and
it has to be the best that she can do
because typically you you were with the
strongest guy otherwise another guy
would kill him and take you with and
kill your kids yeah so I think even like
the way we're designed reproductively
like we can impregnate more multiple
women easily but you get pregnant once
and you're like out of the game for like
a while
if that makes sense and then also it's
like um the whole locking key uh analogy
where a cheap lock can be opened by any
key however a Master Lock can only be
opened by one key so it's the idea that
whatever's behind the lock is precious
and needs to be
withheld at all costs and if it's given
out 3D then it loses value and the key
that can open many locks is also more
valuable yeah
yeah because man I don't think most
girls think that like men are sleeping
around all the time but guys have to
work but I have to work really hard to
be able to get girls they have to figure
out money they have to go to the gym
where we're just 15 14 and guys start
hitting on us it's true and and so it's
it's not impressive to sleep with a lot
of guys and it actually repulses them
because historically they had to ensure
paternity so they had to say I want to
make sure that kid is mine and I'm not
passing on my resources to some some a
kid that's not mine so that's why
they're biologically predispositioned to
like pure women
for relationships they'll screw anything
but so many obsessions with teens
because they peel I would I wouldn't say
what do you mean obsession with teens
because most most guys I know like young
women how how young as young as as is
legal it's legal yes it's a bit much
still
um obsessed with them I think they're
obsessed with the idea of the Purity in
them like if they were if they were 20
and still like that oh they would go for
that but it's just the idea of like
they're still pure they still they don't
I can conquer that can be no other
father it will only be mine yeah yeah
pretty much
yeah and and so men value youth
fertility and beauty and so the younger
you are the more you have of that right
okay because you know men aren't lining
up to date 50 year olds so at some point
it goes away unfortunate
the modern the Modern Woman demonizes
anything that is uh at detriment to her
so for example as us as men when we're
young we realize that
all right when you're like 16 you
realize the local drug dealer who's like
19 will pull up in the Vauxhall Corsa
will take the sexiest girl of the year
and you just have to take it because
you're young and that's it and that's
just the game is the game
you see women when they hit like say
touching 30 they'll go out to to clubs
and they'll say why is everyone in here
a kid or they'll start demonizing men of
their age who are dating 23 year olds
like oh why can't you get a woman your
age and they don't accept that power
dividers now because okay once you see
this you can't really unsee it every
time men have a standard women shame
them for it body cow yeah so every time
so the things that men value they're
shamed for valuing so so for example if
a guy says I want a young girl I want
her to be in shape I want no kids
they're they're saying you're fat phobic
you're [__] shaming
but girls can go on a public platform
and say I deserve this this this and
this and nobody bats an eye
I like I deserve a guy that treats me
right I deserve a guy that makes this
amount of money I deserve a guy that's
this tall and no one will say anything
okay where do you think that comes from
I just think Society is geared towards
women we make 70 to 80 percent of
consumer buying decisions so I just
think everything in the media is for
women except this channel like the video
I think I think um part of it is women
are sold this narrative from such a
young age that you can be whatever you
want and it doesn't matter so like for
example body positivity